[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه
[موسيقى]
بالعكس نهايتها تكون صعبه ده اللي بيحكي
عنه فيلم مليون دولار بيبي واللي بيورينا
معاناه ناجي وازاي بقى وده اللي انا احكي
لك عنه النهارده في حلقه جديده قديمه
[موسيقى]
ماجي بتحبط جدا لكنها بتفضل تروح الصلاه
وهنا بيظهر بطلها المنقذ ايدي ايدي هو
صديق هو موظف عند فرانكي وكمان هو راوي
الفيلم اللي بنشوف الحكايه من المنظوره
اللي بيشجع ماجي وبيساعدها خاصه ان هو
بيشوفها مصممه على التدريب لكنها بتتمرن
غلط وهنا بيتدخل فرانكي وبيقول لها انها
بتعمل حركات غلط فبتقول له يعلمها الصح
فرانكي كان محبط جدا علشان بطلوا اللي
يدربه بجويلي راح مضى مع راعي ثاني بسبب
رفض فرانكي لعروض كتير لمباراه بطوله
[موسيقى]
لكنها اتعرفت انها بتهزم ونفسها دائما
بعدها
المدربين الثاني
المسؤول عن بلي علشان ينظم لها المباريات
بتاعتها وبكده يكون يخلي مسؤوليته تماما
منها ماجي بترفض عرض ميكي ماك بدافع الورق
لفرانكي وبترجع لفرنكي وبتقرر تكمل معاه
حتى لو رافض انها تدخل معارك كبيره وقتها
فرانك بيديها لقب ومش بيقولها معناه غير
في نهايه الفيلم ماجد تكبر وبتدخل معارك
اكبر وبيبقى معاه فلوس كفايه ان هتشتري
لوالدتها بيت ولا لما بتروح مع فرانكي
علشان تشوف رد فعل لوالدتها بالبيت
بتتفاجيء انها متضايقه علشان الحكومه
هتعرف المادي
بتضايق جدا وبتمشي وهي زعلانه خلال الوقت
ده هي وفرانكي علاقتهم بتبقى افضل
بعد مرور الوقت فرانكي بيكون مستعد اخيرا
مليون دولار المعركه
قذره ودائما
فبتبدا اما يجي بالسيطره على القتال لكن
بيلي بتضرب هلاكمه غير قانونيه من الخلف
بعد ما دق الجرس بتاع انتهاء الجوله ماجي
بتقع بقوه على الكرسي في الزاويه وده
بيسبب لها كسف رقبتها وبتفضل مشلوله
وبتفضل تعتمد على جهاز التنفس الصناعي
خلال وجود ماجي في المستشفى بتفضل تستنى
زياره اهلها وبيوصلوا فعلا بس بعد ما
بيكونوا قد نزهه كامله في ديزني لاند
بيوصلوا معاهم المحامي ولما بيشوفهم
فرانكي بيقول لهم ان الافضل ان هم يرجعوا
يغيروا هدومهم بدل ما يدخلوا كده على ما
يجي لكن امها بتتنرفز جدا عليه وبتدعي
تعاطفها مع ماجي وبتدخل على طول هي
واولادها والمحامين وبيكونوا جايبين ورق
نقل من اللي جاي عشان ياخذه فلوس ما كله
كلها لما بتدخل الفرانكي لما اجي بتمنعه
وبيطلع بره ما جبتش ماز جدا منهم وبتطردهم
بره وبتهددهم بالتبليغ عنهم حاله ماجي
بتسوق في المستشفى وبيجيء لها قرحه فراش
بتتثبت في بتر رجلها المصابه وقتها بتطلب
ماجي من فرانكي اصعب طلب ممكن
طلبها طبعا بعدها ما اجي بتاكل لسانها في
محاوله منها للنزيف لحد الموت وده بيذي
فرانكي قوي لان هو بيعملها زي بنته بيروح
فرانك للكاهن وبيقول له على طلب ماجد
فالكاهن بيقول له لو عملت كده مش هتلاقي
نفسك ثاني وبالفعل بيروح فرانك المستشفى
بالليل وبيدي ماجي حقنه مميته وقال لها
قبلها معنى وخش ليه وده معناها حبيبتي او
دمي بيختفي بعدها فرانك من الصلاه كلها
وبعدها تم الكشف عن روايه ايدي على انها
رساله لبنت فرانكي وكان بيحاول يقولها على
شخصيه والدها الحقيقه ولو بتسال الفيلم
نجح ولا لا خليني اقول لك ان فيلم ميري
بيبي يحقق اكثر من 200 216 مليون دولار في
جميع انحاء العالم وكان وراه مبدعين كثير
كده
في حفله جواز الاوسكار 77 وفاز باربعه
افضل صوره وافضل مخرج وافضل ممثله وافضل
ممثل مساعد
بجائزه النيورك تايمز الامريكيه كاحد افضل
فيلم في القرن الحادي والعشرين سنه 2017
بالمناسبه الفيلم متاخد من كتاب روبرارينز
ستوريز فولد كوره واللي كتبوا مدرب
الملاكمه المخضرم والمدير جيري بويل كتب
بويت الكتاب وهو عنده 70 سنه ومات قبل
سنتين من عرض الفيلم على الشاشات فيلم
مليون دولار بيبي من الافلام اللي ما
ينفعش تسمع عنها بس لازم تشوفه وتستمتع
بكل مشهد فيه وبتفاصيل التحديات اللي
هتقابل كل بطل فيه شوف الفيلم دلوقتي
واستناني الحلقه اللي جايه في فيلم جديد
من ما وراء الافلام المقدم بالعربيه فوكس
[موسيقى]